I'm pleased to introduce Dr. Jeffrey West.
He's very likely,
um,
had the origin of our 20% time. It's a
funny story. Um, we have there over lunch.
I invite you to ask him about it sometime.
He's a theoretical physicist.
He's primary interest, have been in
fundamental questions of physics,
especially those concerning
the elementary particles,
their interactions and
cosmological implications. Um,
as long term fascination in general
scaling phenomena involved into a highly
productive collaboration on the origin
of universal scaling laws that pervade
biology from the molecular
genomic scale up through my,
the country on cells to whole
organisms and ecosystems.
And many of these ideas I think form
the basis of his book that he's here to
talk about today.
Scale the search for simplicity and unity
in the complexity of life from cells
to cities, companies to ecosystems,
milliseconds to millennia.
Please join me in giving
him a warm welcome today.
Thanks sir.
Whoops. White. So I'm going
to give a, you know, a, um,
uh,
roads of this short presentation,
short meaning I hope I can give
it about 30 minutes. Uh, uh,
giving an overview of what this book is
about and it covers a huge territory.
It's so, it's very impressionistic.
It'll be a nontechnical.
The book is not technical.
The presentation will be not technical,
but it deals with a lot of deeply
technical and challenging problems.
And, um, it's, uh, it's
encapsulated in the title,
which is here.
But there was this cute thing that penguin
press who produced the book produced.
I can't help showing it to begin.
Uh, this, uh, we just kind of fun.
There you go.
So I'm a physicist. Um, as
the set of new introduction,
I said most of my career doing high energy
physics quarks and gluons and string
theory of dark matter and
so on and so forth. And, um,
uh,
in a way what this book is about and what
this talk is about is sort of taking,
uh,
that way of thinking and asking how far
can you push it in terms of thinking
about, um, a biology organism,
mid life and a socioeconomic
lines. And, uh,
so a lot of what I'm going to talk
about is going to be, uh, about,
uh,
cities and companies.
And I'm also going to talk a bit
a little bit about biology. Um,
but, uh, the framework
really is the whole, is,
is trying to ask to what extent can
you make a quantitative predictive
mathematize them computable
science of biological phenomena,
biomedical phenomena.
And, uh, in some ways,
more importantly for what I want to
talk about socioeconomic phenomena. Um,
and really the passion behind all this
was the fundamental question as to
whether this extraordinary enterprise
that we've developed over the last, well,
most 10,000 years,
maybe you don't need really the last
couple of hundred years is actually
sustainable in principle. So that's
what I'm going to try to lead up to.
And, uh, as I said, I
am, it's inspired by, uh,
work that I've done in
physics and in biology.
So the first thing is that I've already
knows that we live in a, uh, um,
an exponentially, whoops, is this a India?
Someone helped me if I press
that. Oh, picture bridge.
Actually, I talk about
bridges in the book. I run
the design of bridges.
Oh, very good. So we already
knows we live in a, in a, uh,
exponentially expanding universe.
But what is often not appreciated is
that of course we live in a exponentially
expanding socioeconomic
universe. And it's, you know,
some figures that this that
you're probably familiar
with in one form or another,
but, um, you know,
200 years ago when this
country was founded, almost,
there was a must entirely
agricultural and rural,
and it's now become
overwhelmingly urbanized a,
it's about 82% of the US
population lives in cities.
And just a couple of years ago,
uh,
the world cross this amazing point of
being over half a of an eyes and it's
moving towards that 70 to 80%,
uh,
mark in the next 50 years.
So this is extraordinary,
but it's sort of interesting to put it
into sort of more a capturable terms.
Whoops. And that is if you just
average, so the next 30 to 40 years,
that is equivalent to adding about almost
one and a half million people a week
to cities building that infrastructure.
That means building a New
York metropolitan area
every couple of months or a
Seattle, the city of Seattle every
few days. That's what's going.
It's sort of extraordinary.
So this is everything that we do
is sort of with that backdrop,
this phenomenon that is taking
place. And um, you know,
it's again represented by this.
This is China.
China was very slow to urbanize the,
the yellow there is the rural,
the red is the urban and it's cross the
halfway mark and it is heading towards
this 80% mark very rapidly.
And that is represented by its claim to
be building two to 300 new cities in the
next 15 to 20 years,
each and excess of a million people.
So the stress and strain
on energy resources, uh,
and in particular on the social fabric are
phenomenal. And this is just China. Uh,
we have India, we have Latin America, and
of course we have Africa. And of course,
all of this is a reflection
of this incredible,
super exponential growth. The
population. I, um, you know, that's,
this is,
this begins when we started to urbanize
when we stopped being hunter gatherers
and, uh, you know, it's,
it's sort of extraordinary.
I look at this graph and I'm
looking up there. Um, uh,
I was born in 1940 where there were just
over 2 billion people on the planet.
There's now seven and a half million,
and by the time many of you are dead, uh,
it will be 10 to 12 million.
So that's unbelievable.
And so somehow we've got to sort of think
of this in much bigger terms then what
its effect is even just on global warming
or in the environment or on a health
and energy.
And so we're going to,
we need to sort of develop
a much bigger picture.
And all of this is manifested again
in this idea of open ended growth,
which has been so extraordinarily
successful and, and
bringing us to this point.
And just to give another marker,
another metric of it,
this is the growth in the US GDP.
Um,
since roughly the civil war,
if you didn't invested $1 in the,
in the,
in the stock market in about 1870,
it would now be worth $1 million
even allowing for inflation.
So this is just a metric of the
extraordinary expansion of the economy.
Now all of this is bound up
with the development of cities,
the urbanization that
I talked about briefly.
So one can immediately identify
that the fate of the planet,
you tell me what to press,
it's marvelous that this is happening.
I love it. This is the problem. I
do the stories. I could telegraph
my,
the way I gave a talk at the Google and
then mountain view about five years.
And uh, you know, I'm very old fashion.
I've got three times as old as most
seizures cause I can tell. But, uh, I,
uh, I said a young coming and then
two days before four, I said, um,
uh, they said, send us the,
uh, you know, the PowerPoint.
Say PowerPoint. Just be kidding. I
said, I haven't been to transparencies.
I know I'm going to go back.
And they said, what's that?
I explained and you know,
they had to go out and Google had to go
up and buy the overhead projector so I
can give my tour, which was,
oh, we, I can just talk.
Maybe I'll just have to talk.
If you don't mind.
I'll use my PowerPoint
as notes to just talk.
You were Miss Graphs and yours is going
to have to use your vivid imaginations.
So, let's see. So I'd love
to be pictures of cities.
So,
so the point is that the future of the
planet is now really the future of the
cities of the future decisions
in the future of the planet.
The fate of the planet is completely
intertwined when what's happening in
cities.
And uh,
so there is an urgent need to develop
a deep understanding of cities,
not just a qualitative
narrative version of cities,
which is been the traditional way
of thinking about cities, but fire,
urban geography, urban
planning, urban economics,
but some of the more
scientific viewpoint and ask,
is it even possible?
Is it possible to have that?
Is it possible to develop a science
of cities that could lead to an
understanding, their
structure, their dynamics,
that growth and evolution so that we
can understand likewise the growth.
That's the socioeconomic I economic life
that we've developed and lead into what
I've tried to term a sort of,
so to speak of grand unified
theory of sustainability.
So, um, that's been been, uh,
that's been my passion for the
last several years. And, um,
uh, you know, we all understand why
cities are very attractive. You know,
it's a place where there's greater
opportunities, there's great a buzz,
there's more cultural events.
Um,
there's greater access to
good restaurants and so forth.
And this has been the great attractor.
Is it an account?
And I've marvelous pictures.
Um, but you know, all of this, all of the
marvelous things. And look, you, I mean,
my God, you live in one of the most
energetic cities on the planet. I mean,
[inaudible] my God,
I was looking at all the construction
downtown. It's, it's phenomenal.
Um, and um, uh, but all
of that requires energy.
So fundamentally at some fundamental
level, obviously energy has to come in.
And I'm sure most of you are familiar
with the second or third dynamics,
um, which says roughly speaking, that a,
if you try to create lots of
border, then you pay, oh, sorry.
Okay. So one second. Let
me see where I can. Okay.
So that's what I was saying.
I didn't, uh, and similar,
and this is just the images of the
images of why cities are exciting and
important, but all of that requires
energy. And as I said, you know,
from the second law of thermodynamics,
which afterwards,
the most fundamental law or physics,
it's the one thing that is immutable, uh,
creating order necessarily produces
disorder, producers, entropy.
And uh, so in creating cities
and creating socioeconomic order,
we of course, crepes, economic
entropy, which means that we have,
we create things like
this and this and this,
this and this. And of course it,
this social unrest and so on.
All of these are created
by this extraordinary
phenomenon and much of what's
going on in the world in terms of, uh,
this kind of unrest in even if it's,
it's put in cultural and political and
ethnic terms is almost certainly a large
part of that is just due to this
extraordinary phenomenon that's going on.
And one of the questions to ask is this,
is,
is this what cities are
going to end up looking like?
Is it all going to end up being
sort of slums and so forth,
which is happening in many parts
of the world or even this. Uh,
and so that's what I want to
sort of lead up to. So you know,
when we think of cities, and I just
been talking about Seattle moment ago,
you sort of,
the image is one of the physicality of
the city that is the infrastructure,
the roads, the, the
buildings and so forth.
When you think of Paris,
you think of the Eiffel Tower
and the boulevards and so forth.
I think New York skyscrapers,
but in fact most important part of
the city is of course the people.
Because the whole point of the city is
people and the whole point of the city,
it's the fist facilitate
interactions like this.
So this is really what you
should think of as a city.
That there's the backdrop,
the physicality,
the roads, and the uh, transport systems.
And the buildings are really the stage
upon which interaction takes place.
And there's a marvelous picture of Rome
where you see that the backdrop has been
there for 2000 years.
People have changed,
but there's still a place
to provide interaction.
And there's a marvelous picture of
New York hundred 20 years ago or so.
And you can viscerally feel, um,
you know, the entrepreneurship,
the idea creation and so forth
that's taking place there.
And a, this is what city is a foreign.
Again, those buildings are still there.
The people are no longer there.
There's different people.
They're not on the streets,
they're in buildings.
But those buildings and that stage
is to facilitate interaction,
to create wealth, to create ideas, to
innovate and so on. Places like this.
That's what sentence of four.
So I'm one of the dynamics,
uh,
any socioeconomic system when in fact
of any complex system is the tension
between the physicality,
this physicality,
the energy and the resources,
the buildings in this case. Um,
uh, but the flow of energy,
the metabolism of the system,
um, uh, the,
the tension between that
and the information exchange
that goes on between parts.
Yup.
Can I wait till the end? And I bring
that up again because that's very, uh,
that's a, um, a very challenging,
has been a question for,
you know, what is the city
and we'll come back to that,
but I need to go through stuff and then
I will give you a definition of a city,
an operational definition.
So there's this tension between,
so to speak, the feminine dynamics
of the Information Exchange, uh,
that those pictures we
show. So that show that, um,
and also the recognition that, uh,
almost all the problems that we face,
whether it is global warming or
it's the question of, uh, you know,
do we have enough energy and enough
resources, questions of trying collusion,
health and so on. All these are generated
in an urban environment primarily.
And so,
uh,
organization can be thought of as the
source of the tsunami of problems that we
face across the planet,
but they're also the solution because
of the very reasons I said earlier.
They are magnets,
uh,
that's or vacuum cleaners that
suck up the smart people or the,
uh,
you know,
almost all the great ideas and what's
all the wealth that's created is created
in some kind of urban environment.
And associated with that is that
all of these various things,
this is just an,
uh,
an incomplete laundry list of many things
that are part of associate economic
system. Uh, let's see. She like, yeah,
I'm going to press that,
that no,
I'm not just good at flipping
transparency as a parent.
Okay. So an important aspect, you know,
typically we treat each one of these
roughly speaking autonomously or semi
autonomously. That is a, you know,
like we think only of global warming
and we only think of energy or the only
thing,
health issues and so on.
But all of these are themselves
highly complex systems.
They're each adapting and evolving and
they're all most importantly interacting
with each other. And so, um,
if you only treat one and only think of
one and stave stayed quite stove pipe,
you have the,
the classic problem of all kinds of
unintended consequences because of the
neglected interactions
with everything else.
So it's very important to develop a,
an integrated,
bigger picture in order to see all these
things as part of an integrated whole.
So now I'm going to switch gears and
I'm going to talk a little bit about
biology as a way to leading back into
some of these questions of cities and
ultimately that of companies
and then sustainability.
So, um, uh, first of all,
if you're going to have a
science of one of these systems,
kind of physics of a city,
there's no way that there's a Newton's
laws of cities that meaning that a bunch
of principles from which you can
calculate anything so that, uh,
uh,
you know,
physics is best represented
by the fact that we can,
we know the position of a satellite to
almost any degree of accuracy so that we
can use our cell phones.
And bounce things off and the
whole it enterprise could work.
But that works because we can do
that to any degree of accuracy.
But the idea that you could do that in a
complex adaptive systems lot such as an
organism or a city as
clearly extremely unlikely.
Nevertheless,
you could have a theory that is
what I will call core screen.
That is you can get the generic properties
of the system will understand those.
So there's kind of an in between of
not being able to address any of the
questions to having something
predictable to any degree of accuracy.
Maybe we can predict some
coarse grained low resolution,
uh, characteristics of these
systems. So his, um, an example,
first question, why do we live a hundred
years and not a thousand? So we're,
why is it that I can say
with absolute certainty,
everybody in this room will be
dead in a hundred years? Um,
where in the hell does that
hundred years come from?
Why isn't it a thousand years as I say
here on million years or just 10 years?
Why isn't everybody dead already like
a mouse? If you're all mice by the way,
mice, tissue mice, uh,
almost identical to ours.
So why is it the bed dead? They would
all be dead if he were all mice.
So why is that?
Where does that number come from?
How is it generated from
mini color scales or um, why,
why is it that most of us had to sleep
with the order of eight hours last night?
Why not 15 or 16?
One can mounts or three or four,
like an elephant has to see three or
four years and the way you're learning a
couple of hours. So we're in the hell
do those numbers come from? What is,
what is the dynamic that's
giving rise to those? And um,
uh, so these are coarse grained
questions and the answers will be caused,
screened.
The idea that you can predict the
lifespan of a particular individual is,
maybe you could do it
with some probability,
but the idea that you can predict it
accurately is clearly not feasible.
So similarly, when we move
into the socioeconomic things,
I'll citizen companies,
just large organisms they came
out of biology is, you know,
to what extent is Google
or Seattle biological, um,
and why is it that a given that,
that we all die,
which you've already talked about,
but all companies die.
But cities almost never do.
It's almost impossible to kill the city.
You can think of cities that have died,
but to modern times you could do
dropped atom bombs on cities and uh,
25 years later they're fine.
Whereas a small fluctuation,
relatively speaking in the
stock market and you lose,
lose a twa or Lehmann brothers,
et cetera. So companies are,
are fragile, cities are very
resilient. And you could ask,
could you get a series of
components and could you predict?
And here you're going to throw me
out when Google would disappear,
as I will show you a whole companies
eventually will like human beings.
So there's just a picture.
So you know what happens here or what
happened here for crying out loud.
Mick Jagger lie have it to come from the
same part of London are the same age.
So they, uh, so here's the,
here's we, one of these.
We want to, we are a mammal. And
despite the fact that, uh, you know,
we look very different,
we looked different from them and they
look different for each other and they,
uh, they're in their immediate
environment is quite different.
It swims in the ocean and discoveries
around, we brought on two links,
nevertheless to an extraordinary
degree of accuracy,
18 90%. We are actually scaled
versions of one another.
When you look at anything that you
can measure about the many thing
physiological or anything about
their life history. So for example,
here's the most fundamental quantity.
It's called metabolic rate and then how
much food you need to eat per day to
stay alive.
And that's plotted on the vertical axis.
And on the horizontal axis is the size
and it's partially logarithmically up by
factors of 10. And what you see is
something extraordinary. Here's the most,
probably the most complex phenomenon
in the universe, metabolism,
taking stuff and making it into life.
Yet despite it being so extraordinary
complex and despite the fact that each one
of these organisms as evolved by natural
selection with its own unique history,
each subcomponent, each organ of these
systems, each cell type is genome,
has evolved with its own unique history,
in which case you see this idea of
so randomness of natural selection,
in which case when you
plotted something like this,
you expect these points
to be all over this graph.
They've all lined up on a very simple
straight line when plot it in this way,
and of course you plotted logarithmically
at first because you got a mouse in an
elephant.
If you tried to put the mouse here and
you wanted to put the elephant on the
same graph and it were linear, of course
it would be somewhere, I dunno. In Tacoma.
Yes. Anyway, so this is a way
of getting it on that side,
on the same graph. And you can see
there's an extraordinary regularity,
extorting irregularities,
even more amazing when you realize that
the slope of this line is less than one
because if it were one,
you sort of vaguely understand
it because if it were linear,
you said where he doubled
the size of an organism,
you've doubled the number of cells.
Therefore you double the amount of energy
that's needed. Not the case at all.
The slope of is I've written down is
very close to the 0.75 and three quarters
so that every time you double you
actually saved about 25% so there's an
extraordinary economy of
scale as you go up in signs.
So elephant is more economic,
it's cells work less hard than yours,
but yours was work less hard
than your cats for example.
So those two things are actually scaled
version to one another. So there it is,
I said it again there,
but most importantly in addition
to this is that this is true of any
physiological or life history event.
Here's a mundane one. This is heart rate,
your heart rate.
And you can see again,
it's a pretty good straight
line on this log log part.
And the slope of this is close to minus
one quarter minus because it's negative
and his, you, this is your white
matter, the gray matter in your brain.
This is the um, uh, the,
the cable is versus the,
uh, the operating part. And you can
see this fantastic straight line.
This is good.
This is very close to five quarters is
jeans and there's more fluctuations here,
but the slope is very
close to one quarter.
And so what you see emerge from
this is this incredible, um,
simplicity underlying this
extraordinary complexity. Um,
uh,
with something also amazing is that all
of these seem to have slopes that are
simple multiples of this number one,
quarter four plays some
fundamental role in all of biology.
So when I could spend the rest
of the afternoon showing you
75 or some of these damn graphs of almost
everything that can be measured looks
like this. Um, now this is
not exactly an equation,
but I decided to leave this
in any way. This, actually,
this actually is a copy of a
transparency I showed at that.
Google they, that's why
I put it in. So, um, so,
so I said heart rates decrease.
That's what that symbol means decrease.
We're in that, we're plotting
it with a slope of one quarter,
but it turns out lifespan.
How long you live approximately increases
increases with that slope of one
quarter. So if you multiply
these two things together,
the increase of lifespan
going with plus one quarter,
the heart rate decreasing with one quart,
you multiply them together,
the one quarters cancel. So heart
rate times lifespan is an invariant.
Doesn't change what circle,
but what is heart rate times lifespan is
the number of heartbeats in a lifetime.
And that's the same for all of us,
which is spiritually beautiful and
scientifically challenging to understand.
And that number is about one and a half
billion times and is the data and see,
so this is number beats for lifespan
versus the size and rotten that's I can,
those are quickly do the calculation.
We are an exception for very good
reasons which have had had time.
I will come back to it at the end.
So what the hell?
Where the hell do all these
extraordinary scaling laws come from?
What is it that's driving them?
What is it that's constraining the
randomness and chaotic nature of natural
selection?
And the idea that I developed with some
marvelous biologist was an underlying
them is something that's common to all
these systems and is common in fact or
socio economic systems.
And that is that you've got to,
you have huge numbers of
components and you have to service,
those were the cells,
customers or workers you have to
serve as those in a roughly speaking,
democratic, inefficient manner. And
you do that of course by networks.
And those networks are typically
branching hierarchical networks.
So the idea is that
networks underlying this,
and it is the mathematics and
physics of these networks,
these networks, there's different
kinds. There's that's you.
This is also you that your brain
as the white to grey, right?
This is also you,
that's inside yourselves.
And that that's a mitochondria
inside the cell. Now own networks.
And the idea is that even though
these networks have different physical
structures,
the mathematics and the generic principles
underlying the structure and dynamics
of flow on these networks are
universal and generic. Okay.
So,
um,
so now you have this theory that, uh,
where you understand all of these, uh,
the list of scaling of all of these,
but you also have a theory for
understanding how these networks work,
not only the structure that is,
if you wanted to ask me what is the
radius length blood flow rate a stress on
the 12th branch of your arterial network.
There's a formula in my office,
you can put in the numbers but in the
program and you'll get the right answer
for a cat, a dog, a
hippopotamus, whenever. So it's,
it's quite powerful. And, uh,
once you have such a theory,
you can apply it to many things. And some
of them are things that I talked about,
which I'm not going to talk about now,
like aging and sleep.
But some things I will talk about
very briefly is growth because,
uh, that's, that's crucial in
your development obviously.
And it's come up with something
maybe that I just saw an opening.
Yes,
you gotta Ah,
they are that you. So how did you grow?
Let's do this quickly before I go.
Um,
so what is that?
So you eat lunch, you're
metabolize the food. Uh,
it turns it into ATP molecules that
carry your energy and that gets delivered
through the networks to
yourselves at the cells.
It repairs and maintains them.
It replaces those that have
died and then grows new ones.
So there's the equation in English,
it's some goes to maintenance and some
goes to growth. And by the way, uh,
I was in, in a few minutes, I'll
do this for cities and companies.
And it's the same equation basically.
I mean,
you have to adjust what
you mean by these things,
but it's fundamentally the same if you do
that and you put that into mathematics,
that English into mathematics
with this, the, the,
the theory that has been developed. Then
here's an example of this is our growth.
Our meaning mammals is a rat and a,
these are data points.
And that's the prediction of the theory.
And amazingly with the same parameters,
the same few parameters like
the of a sale and so on.
You can predict the growth curve for
any animal and then the theory tells you
how to rescale all those results.
I could have shown you lots of those
growth goals so that everybody has to grow
in the same way. And here's just
some small sampling of those.
You see they all grow.
They all fit on the same universal
curve that is predicted by the theory,
even by the way cancer tumors,
which are we'll come back to in a minute.
But the important thing is there's a
universal theory for growth and most
importantly for what I want to say is
that in explains why it is that you grow
quickly at the beginning and something
that should have maybe bothered you.
Why is it they should go on eating, which
you don't go on growing. I mean you,
you do,
I mean a little bit this way,
but you don't grow what's
called onto genetically.
You stay pretty much the same size.
And then you have this stable
configuration you get into.
And by the way,
this,
this idea that most organisms reach a
stable size and stop growing is crucial.
And the sustainability of life and why
life has been around for two to 3 billion
years. Uh, and of course just
jumping ahead, this is terrible.
When you think of an economy or a
company or a city you're supposed to be,
you know, you're not supposed
to go bend over like that.
It's not supposed to start.
And,
and what is also very
important is the reason,
if you trace back why
is you stopped growing.
It is intimately related to this
what I called sub linear scaling.
The fact that metabolic rate
scaled with an exponent,
meaning that slope of that
graph with less than one,
the three quarters was crucial
that it goes, this bends over.
And I could elaborate on that.
Anyone's interested later. So there's,
it's still showing great. So here's
a summary. Some biological things.
We have these extraordinary
scaling ignores their nonlinear.
There's these quarter pounders
and expresses an economy of scale.
The bigger you are, the message needed
per cell per capita to stay in line. Uh,
I didn't emphasize this,
but going along with that sub linear
scaling is that the pace of life
systematically slows heart speed,
slower oxygen diffuses
across membranes, uh, slower.
You live longer.
And in fact you could contract a
elephants life completely down so that it
overlaps exactly that of a mouse
if you follow the scheme north. Um,
I said growth stocks,
growth stocks,
and I only intimated it you
die when Ben Ben's over.
Stop growing and then you die.
Okay,
let's use this now as a point of
departure to talk about cities.
So I said this already. First question
is, is scaled versions of one another.
Is Seattle justice scaled
down New York City,
which is a scaled up Santa fe where I
live or scaled down Chicago or they scaled
version one, but it sure as hell don't
look alike. They have different histories,
cultures, geographies and so
on. On the other hand, um,
their own network systems,
roads and electrical lines and so on,
their transport systems and the
supplied by energy networks.
And perhaps most importantly,
that I emphasized earlier. Um,
they will have people in them and,
uh, people form social networks.
It's a classic social network,
social network nodes of people.
And those are the interactions.
You're probably more familiar with this
than I am, but these are social networks.
Um, and two points I want
to emphasize about this.
One is that there's a modularity to these
networks generally because people have
families and they have jobs with
groups and departments and so on.
So people have said it's
not just individuals,
but we formed groups of various sizes
and most importantly illustrated on this.
You know, we tend to draw pictures like
this when we do our network theory. Um,
but we tend to forget,
especially when used words like the cloud,
that all of these have to be somewhere.
People have to be actually somewhere
when they're on their iPhone or on their
computer or whatever, doing
Facebook. They have to be, you know,
on a road in the office, in the
bathroom somewhere. They have to be.
So they are glued,
people are glued whether they
like it or not to being in place.
So there's an integration
between place and information.
So are they, are cities scaled
versions one or the other.
But here's some first data that we
look at and this was something mundane.
This is gas stations petro here because
these people I worked with where we're
at the eth in Zurich,
uh,
and uh,
you can see this is a,
there's four European cities and
you've seen bay scale pretty well.
And the dotted line is the youngest
like biology, it's sub linear.
That is the bigger the city,
the less gas stations needed per capita.
Not Surprising, but what is surprising
is there are roughly the same slope,
meaning that you're saying the
same amount every time you double,
no matter where you are.
And that is about 15%.
The slope of this is about point a
five rather than 0.75 in biology.
Furthermore,
if you look at any infrastructure that is,
if you look at the
length of all the roads,
you look at the length of all the
electrical lines, the power, the,
the how many mortar lines,
the gas line, whatever,
whatever you can measure
about infrastructure. They
all have this character,
they all scale in this way.
They all scare with the same smoke
about 0.85 and it's the same,
not just in these four European
cities for European countries,
but across Europe, across the United
States, across China, across Japan,
Colombia, Chile, wherever,
wherever you can get data
and look exactly like this,
all infrastructure scales in the same way.
And one interesting consequence
of that is in a sense,
you get this economy of scale.
That means the bigger the city,
the less entropy that is produced.
And therefore it's up here.
The carbon footprint gets lower
per capita, the bigger the city.
So the greenest city in the United
States is New York City and one of the
shittiest in that sense,
a Santa fe where I live,
even though it's in Delek
compared to living in New York.
So, uh, that's fantastic.
But what is even more amazing is
if you look at socioeconomic wants.
It is things that never existed until we
started learning language and building
communities and ultimately cities,
things like wages and something called
someone named Richard Florida called
super creative people like everybody here,
professional people.
If you ask how does that scale with city
size parked it in the same logarithmic
boy, then you get a similar as
more fluctuations, more noise,
but you get scaling but you get a slope.
There is now bigger than one.
It's called Super Linear scaling,
which means that instead of
every time where as you increase,
you get an economy of scale.
The bigger you are,
the less per capita for
socioeconomic quantities, wages,
super creative people.
Bigger you are the more per capita and
the slopes of these are quite similar
around 1.15 what is amazing is that
that's the same for most everything else.
I didn't write it on here.
This is the patents produced as
a function of synthesize size.
This is just over 1.15 this crime
in Japan there's a bit bigger.
This is police tax receipts,
construction restaurants
and Holland and so on.
And here's just a small panel of half a
dozen of these different variables whose
wages are just showed you. Here's
the GDP of France is crime in Japan.
And you can see they all have pretty
much the same slope so that any socio,
not socio economic variable,
no matter what it is,
no matter where it is across the
globe scales in the same way,
which is sort of extraordinary because
there wasn't a congress in 1782 where all
the countries of the world decided this
is how we're going to build cities and
this is how I'm going to build
our socioeconomics system.
And all evolved organically and
amazingly out of all that came something
universal and similar.
Um,
and here's just for the United
States, this is just income, GDP.
Private patents readjusted but
to the same scale, but send,
you can see the same slope.
There's quite a bit of noise in it,
but you can see overall
it's the same kind of thing.
And one of the big questions is, when
the hell does all this come from, why is,
why should that be? So
here it is in English. Uh,
if you double the size of a city, you
know, give an urban system on average,
uh, systematically the income, well,
number of colleges,
educational places created people,
but also all these bad things, please
aids, flu, crime, social and oh,
these things all increased by about 15%
and at the same time you save 15% on own
infrastructure.
So big cities a good,
if you sort of ignore this, which people
are very good at suppressing crime,
pollution, disease, a big cities, a
good and big bigger cities, even better.
So we're in the hell. Does all this
come from? So you ask yourself,
what is universal about all cities?
What is common across all cities?
And what you quickly realize.
There's something I've emphasized earlier.
The thing that's common is
that they are for people,
and it may sound sort of obvious,
but amazingly,
if you become familiar
with urban planning,
urban architecture of an economics,
what you discover is people
rarely play any role in those.
Those subjects was dominated by the
physicality and pure economics of the
system.
And so the idea is in is the universality
of the mathematics and physics of
social networks. The interaction
of people do this underlying this.
And I don't have time again to go into
any of the mathematics and the details of
this to show you where it
comes from. Uh, but um,
one thing I will show
you is the following,
one crucial thing of course about
science is not just to have a theory that
explains the observations,
but to predict things. And a,
so I'm going to be one prediction that
you can make without having to see the
theory just based on that idea.
That's what I just showed you.
And the idea is that the,
the universality of that is because of
the universality of human interactions.
Uh,
so if we could measure the number of
the interaction between people as a
function of city size, it
should track this. Okay.
So how do you do that? Well, that's
been very hard until recently,
but now everybody carries of course,
cell phone,
which means everybody has a
little detective with them.
Sure you're very familiar with, with like
maybe probably exploited in many ways,
I'm sure. Uh, but everybody
has one. And so it's like,
it's like the molecules in this room,
of course,
it's almost as if everyone is tagged so
we know exactly where it is, you know,
where it's moving with
interacting with and so on.
So with some colleagues at MIT,
we were able to get hold of this data
of billions and billions of a cell phone
calls between people in
various places and then just,
uh, do the analysis and count, uh,
how the number of interactions between
people scope, city size. And by the way,
an interaction was I call you.
And within six months you call me back.
So we have a relationship now, six
months, if you could make it three months,
you can make it through.
It's up to you. But, um,
we to establish an interaction,
a relationship. So we did that.
And here's the result.
And you see down the bottom and you
see it's not the same slope as this.
And there's two countries on this planet.
One is the UK and the other is Portugal.
And you can see it agrees
with the predictions.
So it's very strong evidence
that underlying this is
and this theory of social
networks.
Now I'm going to finish off very quickly.
I've gone too long being
delayed by some of this,
but I'll try to finish off
very quickly. Um, first of all,
I mentioned earlier that the
network dynamics in biology
leads to the slowing of
the pace of life. That's the
sub linear, the three quarters,
the super linear behavior of socioeconomic
metrics and the network underlying
it. And by the way, I should
say one thing about the network.
The super linearity comes about because
of the positive feedback loops that we
create. When we interact. I talked to you,
you have a discussion that you talked to
him and then we three have a discussion
and a blood. It's what
goes on here. Of course,
that's what makes the whole system work.
And that has this positive
exponentiate eating behavior,
which leads to the super linear behavior.
That's sort of the words for the
mathematics that goes into this. Uh,
but that leads also has this curious
thing that if you have the superintendent
behavior and sort of the
pace of life slowing down,
it speeds up in a
predictable fashion and his,
so we've looked at many things
that in his one whimsical one,
this is heart rates,
this is biology decreasing with sides.
This is walking speed in
cities as a function of size.
And this is pushing the theory
a little bit, but you know,
you're still part of a network when
you're walking and you can see it's as
fluctuations.
This is ancient data by the way.
It wasn't part of this this way, but you
can see it's very good. And that was,
that was basically the,
that was the prediction from the theory.
And interestingly,
here's something that I found in a
British newspaper a few months ago.
This is the city of Liverpool.
And here's what it says underneath,
there's amazing research revealed almost
half the nation fouled the slow pace of
high streets to be the
biggest shopping bugbear,
not that noise and the
pollution and all the rest.
It's the other fucking
people going too slow. Sorry.
Take it as frustration.
And here it is. So here
is a fast lane. They put a
fast lane for walkers.
There's just from as a niche,
that was the first thing they did it.
So I'm going to miss this
and marvelous quote here.
Oh here's something I see you buying
the iPhone five and then shortly after
Apple Watch and some old one,
the iPhone six and then we've got the
bloody iPhone seven driving us nuts.
Okay, onward. So here's
the growth equation.
I want to go quickly through growth.
So it's the same kind of thing.
I sent it earlier. You know
what you have to cost. No,
you got to add up everything that's
coming in and some goes to maintain
everything that's here or maintain
all the city streets and the roads and
maintain all the people and some roads
grows new infrastructure and roads,
new people and so on.
So you have to put that on.
This is just a cartoon of it and you're
taught them to mathematics. And when you,
when you did an embark,
Jim got this, you saw,
but now the input,
all of this is super linear and
that instead of giving rise to this,
which would be a disaster
in a socioeconomic system
from our modern capitalist
viewpoint you get, and I just do cartoon
versions of this to give you an idea,
it gives you something very satisfying,
gives you this faster
than exponential growth,
which is what we've seen and I'm not going
to have time to show you all the data
that agrees with this and that's
fantastic. So it's very satisfying.
The theory is very self
consistent and is very predictive,
but it has a fatal flaw.
And you've heard this in different forms.
I'm sure that fatal flaw is this Duffy
line because what the theory says is that
you go to an infinite size of whatever
the metric is that y'all are looking at
in a finite time.
This is called mathematically
a finite time singularity.
That's obviously nonsense.
You can't have an infinite number of AIDS
cases or infinite number of a infinite
amount of wages or whatever you them to.
So somewhere along here,
something changes.
And the theory tells you that the theory
tells you what happens is that as you
approach that singularity, the system
stagnates and then it collapses.
That's what I'd done yet.
So just symbolically written it here.
And that's terrible. Of course.
And that's what we don't want. Uh,
and so the question is how do
we avoid it? Well, we avoided
as we're going along here,
when you realize that of course it's
growth was done within a certain set
paradigm. Certain major
innovation, we discover cold.
What we discovered iron 20,000
years ago or whenever it was a,
we invented computers, we
discovered it. Whatever it is,
something is,
it sets the,
so to speak the backdrop for this.
So it's clear.
If you want to have open endedly group
continue up in any growth somewhere along
here before stagnation and collapse
sets in, you better start over again.
And you do that by major innovation.
So innovation,
nothing new is the thing that resets the
clock and you can start over again and
avoid the collapse inherent
in that senior narrative.
So you start over again,
a book off you go and that's great.
But there's a not the singularity is
going to come cause the same dynamic.
So you better do it again.
Sorry. It didn't, somehow
that's supposed to be there.
Uh, and so on. I'm sorry.
Then what happened here. Yeah,
but you get the idea. So you
had this idea. So you have
a theorem you can produce.
If you want to have open ended growth,
you have to have continuous cycles
of paradigm shifting innovations.
Great. However, is the hitch. I said,
if you go along one of these curves, my
wife gets faster, life is speeding up.
But along with that,
the time between these innovations as
the systematically and predictably get
shorter and shorter. So the
time between innovations, uh,
necessarily get shorter.
And uh,
so just to make up some numbers,
if it took a hundred years to make
a major change a thousand years ago,
now it only takes 15 to 20
years. And so indeed the, uh,
the time between, you know, so
to speak, computers, laptops,
and uh, it was maybe 20,
30 years. I know, whatever.
And so what this says is if you want to
avoid collapse, you got to do it again.
You've got to do it soon.
If I told the analysis shows you've got
to do another major innovation analogous
to it in the next 20 years,
and we can speculate as to
what that might be. If not,
we're going to have a
potential crisis on our hands.
Now, this is not my, I don't know who this
guy is, but I picked it off, but, uh, I,
I got permission to use it. Uh, it's, uh,
but it's someone that did some analysis.
I'm just tying to reach 10 million
customers just to give you a sense.
And it's very similar. And then,
you know, very cuts while has,
has a different view of the
singularity likes the singularity,
but the singularity is sort of
like the coming of the Messiah, uh,
whereas I see a quite the opposite.
But this is his graph actually. And a,
what you see is that in line is,
uh,
what's plotted here is, um, along here,
how long ago and innovation took place
of cells took place a billion years ago
almost. Uh, but, uh,
how long it took to make the
change in the news Billy news ago.
Now it's, you know, 15
years, 15 years ago. So,
and you can fit it all
on the logarithmic plot.
This line is exactly what's
predicted by this theory. You know,
I just tried to outline for you,
so I'm going to finish up very quickly,
extremely quickly. Um,
and I leave hanging.
The question is to, you know what, what,
let's go back to this. What happens
here? You know, the question of collapse,
Ultima collapse. Because if you take
the argument to its absurd conclusion,
you would have to be making a major
paradigm shift every two years,
then read one year and then
every six months, obviously
not. So something has to,
as the change.
Okay?
So I want to finish off
extremely quickly with a,
if I can get there with companies.
So here's a,
here's a summary.
I'm just some cub.
I mean I can show you all the data if
anyone's interested with companies and
what's plotted here. Assets and
income. Just to give you a sense,
the important take home
messages here and what this is,
I think this is Walmart is one of the,
uh,
and you see this some fluctuations here,
but you see this is party
versus number employees.
These a tiny companies of
10 to a hundred people.
But once it gets to be a substantial size,
they followed the scaling pretty well.
And the important thing about
this that it's sub linear.
It's not like it's more
like us. It is not like, um,
cities.
And if you follow the argument through,
and this is what I'm going to zoom,
what did that say?
It said that you stopped growing
and your die.
Okay? So let's look at
that. Here's the data.
This is 30,000 US publicly traded
companies from 1950 to 2010,
just all on one plot. Big
Spaghetti plots, every single one,
okay. And uh, what you see is
what you sort of know here.
They're all these new ones and
human fucking stupid zooming away.
But look at these old farts,
they just sort of hanging in there and
it's going along the top like that.
Now they are this. And then as you see
inflation's been taking out on this,
so the old farts like me and this on
limping along and all the young Turks like
you're zooming and forth and here it
is readjusted to the stock market,
the GDP.
And there it is.
And you can see the dead flat,
which means that a big enough fluctuation
of the stock market and you're in
trouble. That's one reason why
companies die. And I won't go.
I don't have time in this cause I've
gone on too long to tell you about the
dynamic of that. That red
line, by the way, it's daunting
going along. And I can tell you about
Boeing cause I've worked with boy. Um,
so here's the growth.
That's Walmart looking
like a big hockey stick.
But you notice it only goes
in 1994 and here it is,
take into 2008 and that red line
is a prediction of this theory.
And you can see it's
beginning to bend over.
And we'll go the way of all companies.
It will join.
It is already joining this, this lot
and we'll bend over and the question is,
will eventually die.
And this is what this last graph is.
This is plotted, um, what's
just focus on one of these.
This is the probability of dying versus
the company age and it's broken down
into companies of different sizes.
And this is divided into those that
disappear through acquisition and merger.
Those be bankruptcy and liquidation.
But this is one see 100% probability.
So it's very unlikely. It's very rare
for a company to live a hundred years,
you know, I need to do of the, um,
and it's very rare for a company
to go two to 300 years. Um, and uh,
I don't, I don't have time to discuss
that. I discuss it in the book.
I discussed lots of investigations
to be done in an ansys be done.
So our finished there, um, I
didn't complete everything,
but I want to show you one last
graph. I went on way too long. Uh,
there's this one,
one thing I didn't say when we were
discussing metabolism is that, you know,
what is sitting here desperately waiting
for me to finish is operating at 90
watts. So you're, that's
all you're using. You know,
like you use my Nike ones and what says
on this grant is that if you think of
your, that's how you evolve that you
are as a biological animal and Mammo,
the fits perfectly on that metabolic rate.
But if you ask the question
how much energy you need
to stay alive with the kind
of socioeconomic activity you do,
the kind of quality and
standard of living you have,
that number is 11,000 months.
So that's equivalent to each one of us
in this room is acting as if we are about
a dozen elephants or
about 70% of a blue one,
which is almost as big as this
whole many. And uh, you know,
most people, the seven and a half billion
people on this planet and all of them,
all of them want to be like us. They all
want to live it never thousand watts.
So this is a huge pressure.
So, um, uh, I haven't, uh,
I, I'm sort of stopped at before
telling you some speculations about,
uh, you know, survival and collapsed
by viability, sustainability.
But this is just puts the
numbers and to a perspective.
So I finished that and I'm sorry,
I went on for too long.
Some of it was due to this and some
was my home profligacy and, uh,
just getting carried away.
So thank you.
[inaudible] sleep
promote. I didn't rose. I put this
up here. It's all in the book,
but no equations.